element 118 an opium or uuo is the last
element in the periodic table and it's
in the group which contains the noble
gases going from helium right down to
radioactive radon so it is going to be
radioactive so far only three atoms have
been observed first one atom then
another two so it's more than an ankh
William but say more it's more than an
and Kuo diem where we had only one atom
but it's still not very many atoms and
the it's still arguable whether it will
be a gas like radon it may be a solid
just like some of the other end perhaps
a solid that's rather volatile and so
that it would evaporate easily but
nobody knows how it has to be no 118 as
the last element on the periodic table
well formally they could be heavier
elements than 118 but the electrons
that's the negatively charged particles
that surround the positively charged
nucleus are in shells which gradually go
outwards rather like the skins of a an
onion so that element 118 represents the
hole of a shell being filled so we know
that there are no more electrons that
can be easily accommodated and if we
make element 119 which would be an
alkaline metal like sodium or cesium
then we would have to put a single
electron a lot further away from the
nucleus and as soon as you start adding
electrons that are further away the
whole system is expected to become very
much less stable
so if we can only make three atoms of
element 118 something that's going to be
very much less stable is not likely to
be found in the short time though one of
the exciting things about science is
that the unexpected often happens so it
might be that before we've started
updating some of these videos element
119 will be announced and nobody will be
more excited than me